hey what's up guys my name is Samuel
Leeds this is winners on a Wednesday
although it's a little bit of a
different type of video because I'm
analytical Deb and she said I'm already
financially free but I want to come on
one of them from your one of your
training although that might be it
seemed a little bit strange
she'll be explaining what in this video
and also talking about some of the
amazing projects that she's doing
especially now she's doing a massive
development project so stay tuned enjoy
hey Deb thanks for coming down yes I am
and it's just so good to say and you
literally like so out there you were
really quiet before also quiet what
happened oh my goodness all I've changed
we started property quite a while ago a
couple years ago six years ago we did
some training legacy yeah she worked
really great they really helped us on
our journey
and it's been a process over those years
of me fighting so much insecurity and
fear and anxiety to become Who I am that
so when we met you were doing you do
really well in proper say a massive shot
how to to legacy that helps you get
started on your journey
I have interests why wouldn't you were
already doing well and you've been
trained already what made you to make
the decision to then go and invest more
money because you're now Academy now yes
I am which is not cheap it's not it's
very expensive it's like a high-end
property training better so why would
you do that cuz a lot of people say you
know you don't need to invest in
training you can get the information for
free online maybe you can but it's like
a needle in a haystack mostly but if you
if you've already gone on training
programs this way such an interesting
case today if you've already been on
training programs you've already got
loads of deals you when we make you a
lot financially free mm-hmm which is
just insane so this the only this is the
most unique winners window story ever
because you're already financially throw
in the net so I can't
unfortunately I can't put your my tally
chart as someone that we might but that
to me that doesn't matter because I know
that for me it's a bigger mission it's a
bigger purpose so it's not about who did
what
for me it's just your living testimony
that it's possible but I'm just curious
like why did you go
investing more training when you're
already financially free well we did
take some time out we have a little boy
he's nearly 2 so we got to being
financially actually double a financial
freedom figure by the time we had a Tara
and I just took some time out or we both
took time out because we're people had
stopped working at that point and once
we got to the end of that time just
started getting a bit itchy to do
something again for business and
something and we're just thinking about
do we start doing the bite alerts do we
keep doing that again it was quite an
effort
I was driving like four hours each way
to Liverpool and laughs properties are
in Liverpool and I was doing it on my
own it was it would really took a lot
out of me and so we were really trying
to figure out what is that clear we
should be doing next because it was just
such a big drain on our lives about that
season so we took our 18 months out and
then when we were thinking of what
should we do next we just found her on
YouTube and then ended up coming on the
crash course and it's just so good being
there because it kind of gave us an
injection of energy back into property
and why we loved it in the first place
and I know that we never would have got
to where we are now if we haven't spent
all that money in the first place and we
knew that if we wanted to get to where
we want to be you have to you have to
pay for that right but you don't it
doesn't happen by accident and I know we
can't do it on our own
and I'm so grateful for the training
we've already done because there's no
way we would be where we are yeah no I
love that and I think also a bit having
that gratitude that you have a speak so
well of everyone that's helped you along
your journey is awesome for me I'm
continually spending more money on
training yeah it's I don't think you're
ever in a situation most like I've now
arrived yeah you know there's always
there's always more yeah and you were
making what like 4000 pattern of passive
income passive completely passive
planning when we met what's happened
since we've met ours the Academy so far
how has it helped you in your journey
how I mean I know you taking things to a
whole new level now what's going on now
I wanted to do something different we
went to what to watch sure what to do
next and the Academy is basically helped
us figure out exactly what our strategy
was we had this really great
conversation with you
the DfE yeah we just we were just a bit
lost what should we be doing and she
basically said to us
Peter Deb's only do big deals actually
just took all the pressure off I'm like
okay we don't need to go back and do
what we were doing before let's do
something bigger let's have a new
adventure so now we're doing development
and we're also youtubing the whole thing
so we're kind of combining those things
together so the Academy has been amazing
for those for those two reasons the
American remember insight is yourself
with your education education your brand
and then property property class doesn't
it which is it which is incredible yes
people think that would people would
assume I would say invest in property
property property property but actually
I say mister education yeah because if
you're a bigger person you have bigger
knowledge you have a bigger brain you
just get bigger deals yeah yeah and then
secondly is your brand yes because if no
one knows who you are
and this is what I said to you because
when we met you were financially free
you almost like a secret entrepreneur we
were absolutely like I kind of pulled
you out of the closet so so invest in
your brand invest time and resources
into doing videos and then I subscribe
to your channel which is awesome and
then thirdly property yeah so I think
I'm really glad to see you kind of put
yourself out there because now you're
all over the Academy group everyone
knows who you are
talk to us about your like this big
project our project is so exciting so
we're actually living on-site on this
project we sold our house and we bought
a three-bedroom bungalow we're turning
into a five bed detached house adding a
big extension at the back going into the
loft but was super exciting about it is
that there's space into the side of it
in the garden so we're gonna be building
a four-bed detached house there so cool
and we're in a static caravan in the
garden just living there on every matter
when you document in the whole thing
yeah it's a big project the figures on
this death ah so we bought this house
for three hundred and sixty-five
thousand it literally it's got nothing
in it it was walls so everything had
been taken out the ceilings were down
there was no kitchen no bathroom to like
scramble funds to get
and then it's going to cost about
150,000 to renovate I know you like what
530 all in yeah okay so we're hoping to
sell it for 575 that but obviously by
selling that 575 not only do we make a
little bit of money on the property but
then get the land for free this will
keep the land and that's where we're
going to do that have to build a house
so the bungalow essentially pays for
itself and we get the land for free and
that's where we'll do that build and so
that's going to cost about 200 250 to do
that builder but then that's going to
sell for nearly five hundred we should
be making about 200 grand really small
so the advice of just just two big deals
yeah because the thing is it takes just
as much effort to do a small bail oh my
god it does after the big deal I think
it takes more potentially it's just
everything just feels like so detailed
and you just need so many of them yeah
to make any difference
yeah but on a small deal you make a
small now but I need the same effort
yeah so and I think my advice to you
which was love only do big deals the
reason I said that was because you've
done small business you've done
thatalready if I was advising someone
that was starting from scratch I would
probably say listen you're gonna mess up
on your face yeah you're gonna mess up
you better off to mess up on a small
deal than on a big deal so just do a
small be able to start it's just
different people I think in for branding
point of view you've got the ability to
find big deals you've got the experience
you've got they you need to tell the
world you to put yourself out there
that's why I said you needs beyond
winners Wednesday even though you
finally when we met this was really
because I want I wanted to get you in
front of my people yeah because I think
that when you put yourself out there is
even watching people watching this video
than what you thinking I haven't got the
energy the time the equation or the
knowledge of the skills I haven't won on
a legacy training I haven't gone
understanding leads Academy haven't but
I've got money and then there could be
joint venture opportunities there but
you don't know that until you put
yourself absolutely so how is the
branding side of things going in the
past I never posted on Facebook I never
I don't understand how Instagram works I
still don't I
I my life was so private even I'm very
open person and I love people terms of
social media stuff I just I didn't want
anybody to see I mean was doing so many
people like that what do you think why
do you think people like to be super
private I still find it hard to believe
that anyone would be interested in
watching any part of my life I like the
fact that people want to watch me I find
a bit odd yeah I like but I know I'm
doing something exciting and I know
there are people out there who are where
I used to be I know if I can encourage
people so just think differently about
their financial future then making
difference yeah so cool and I think
sometimes what seems really simple to
you you might be Alice's I don't need to
talk about that to me this is obvious
yeah actually someone else yeah it's
really advanced yeah so you can be
really helping people by doing that so
okay so what's what's next sensor over
the next sort of few months or over the
say 2020 what's the what's the plan
what's the vision the vision is to do
for development projects on top of the
one we already doing nice so that could
be commercial to residential conversion
it could be a planning game perhaps
someone else with what we're doing at
the moment new builds anything it's kind
of we can really add value and it's an
in development rather than a property on
it on its own so I do four that's the
goal for this year how did you come
about the crash course and all of our
training and how's it been so far how do
we find the graphical yeah just the
training you're on the the castle just
gives so much information I can't
believe that you have so much there for
free even you didn't learn anything else
you everything you could from that
course you could you could build a whole
business with that she's amazing I
couldn't believe it
I mean all their trainers it just got so
much energy and enthusiasm and passion
and you genuinely believe what you're
talking about that's what I love is that
there is that kind of deep rooted in so
many of the team they all look they're
all behind that all what that vision and
going that that's right we love what we
do talk to me about environment because
I know one of the reasons you told me
when you were thinking about register
for the Academy and
we said to you look you're already
financially free but we think you should
do it as an environment so when we
joined legacy we didn't really engage
much with the community aspect we were
very isolated and I think that just felt
really lonely a whole thing we didn't
have the hole that we just didn't give
us the same vision and purpose that
perhaps we were looking for so with
their part the reason one of the main
reasons we joined the Academy was for
that kind of community aspect and being
in an environment a collection of people
that all want the same thing or go in
the same direction yeah that's so
important
we were so isolated just didn't connect
with people and none of our friends our
family we're doing what we were doing
and some of them really understand why
we were doing it what we were doing and
just having the support the environment
the community the academies but yeah it
can be pretty lonely being an
entrepreneur for sure I don't think I
mean obviously what you do legacy worked
really well invested in our you you
became financially ultimately
financially free almost you have a lot
of friends and the Academy politic
submit your post your post a video but
it was like look etabs your suburbs
which is which is which is absolutely
incredible
what advice would you give to somebody
who was maybe because I meet people all
the time and they're actually
financially free but they're kind of
stuck because and I even have this
myself actually to a point because what
happens is you've run out of money so
you've invested all your money and even
vested all your friends and families
money or whatever you could get hold of
and you've maxed out your credit cards
to buy properties and build a portfolio
which is in turn making you two three
four grand a month and way you
financially free you'd have to work
anymore but then it's like how do you
build from here you know and I see a lot
of people in this situation I don't know
if you can relate to that but it's like
going from okay I'm full-time property
and I'm financially free which is great
but I don't want to just live on the
beach forever I want to build this thing
you know can you relate to that yeah I
think so I think that's how we were
feeling before we joined before we found
the crash course before we went on
Academy
we want to be doing something we just
like floating and not really moving I
think it's like figuring out what that
next layer of dreams are because we've
all got we all want to go further
there's everyone's gonna have a vision
somewhere sometimes it just takes a
little while to find it yeah if you're
really struggling to figure out what
that next thing isn't it doesn't take
much to like open your eyes and just
look at look at the world that is in a
really difficult yes like if you can't
find the vision to help yourself find
the vision to help somebody else so when
I think things that massively impacted
me that you said it's our duty to be
successful and that has actually changed
how I feel about finance is this change
how I feel about wealth because there
are people in so much poverty there are
people are so desperate and we need to
do something about that it's my duty to
be successful because I cannot I can't
do anything as one person but if I can
be mega rich then I can change so much
so the thing that's really on my heart
is the the amount of people at refugee
camps there are 70 million people in a
refugee camp 37,000 people are having to
leave their homes everything we're doing
yeah I just don't think that's okay so
that's my passion that's like why I like
further down the road that's where I'm
headed I'm not doing that right now
because I need to get myself in a place
where I can actually make a difference
I'm gonna I wanna be I wanna be mega
rich and then I'm gonna do something
about it yeah that's awesome it's
clearly passionate that's why we were
attracted to you you know in the early
days you were attracted to us I think
people sometimes think and I'm me being
from a church background I know you as
well I don't know all your experiences
or what happened but it's easy for
people to misunderstand you when you
want to be successful because people
think oh you just want to be really rich
so you can live in luxury but actually
you know we believe that if you've got
the ability and the gifting and you're
in the country to make a lot of money
but you don't because of apathy or
laziness or fear yeah actually that's
selfish oh it's so selfish yeah it's
wrong it's not right but we have so much
and so much opportunity we are so
blessed to be in this country and
everyone can
about politics and the NHS or whatever
forever but the fact that we're born
here or have come here live here it's
amazing there's so much opportunity and
we owe it to the rest of the world to
make a difference and making money as
well you know people think okay so
you're gonna sue so what you're saying
the Debs is you're gonna make a lot of
money and get rich by being ruthless and
then you're gonna be generous with the
money but actually you can only make
money by helping people in the first
place yeah yeah because money is a
certificate of thanks yeah so when our
tenant when your tenant are you that
money that makes you financially free
you deserve that money because you
provide a good accommodation let me do
it well you know a bad landlord right I
know we do it properly and the motivated
seller yeah who you bought the property
of is you know this person was really
starting yeah and you they accepted your
offer because that was good for them
yeah absolutely
so in business Albert Einstein I know
quite a lot about has done a lot but one
of my favorite quotes that he says is
don't try and be successful try and be
valuable and when you're valuable the
success will follow and I just think you
know in business be valuable
you've got the god-given brain you've
got the the ability be really valuable
helpful or people make a lotta money and
then with that money you have a duty and
obligations and be generous and happen
to help people are less fortunate than
yourself and I love your big purpose
your vision the fact you put yourself
out there
what would you sign them to to somebody
who was just like feeling really stuck
or you know unmotivated someone that
just what we wanted to really want it
but just was struggling to get the
motivation I think you need to really
embrace the things that you find
difficult I think normally there's a
reason why you're not motivated
there's a reason why you're sluggish and
you don't want to go 50 and do that and
that's normally because there's a fear
or there's an insecurity there's
something behind that is a reason why
you think you can't do it so why would
you try if it's not gonna work I think
if you can embrace whatever is that is
keeping you back then you can actually
move
and for me that was anxiety and really
struggled with anxiety from period of
time when we were building our portfolio
and until I actually faced it and
acknowledged it because my tendency was
just to stick my head in the sand and
and just keep going keep getting busy
pretending to be a property investor
with stuff rather than really doing the
actions that needed to be done in order
to be successful yeah and it's how I
looked at anxiety and thought I don't
want to be that person yes
you can't get through it and I think if
you're not feeling motivated is there a
reason why is there something that's
that the under motivation is just a
symptom of something underneath that is
it's holding you back because you
actually don't want to you don't face
that fear you don't want face things I
do so I think it's not being brave I'm
looking at it in the face and being like
I don't want to be that and that isn't
me anxiety isn't me anxiety is coming
against me I'm gonna fight it do you
think you just choose the person that
you become yes absolutely
and actually for up for me that was a
massive turning point in dealing with
anxiety actually we had peace and I my
husband we were having a conversation in
our old house and then I study we've got
this had this really big whiteboard and
I just drew a line down the center and I
thought Deb's now on one side and then I
did Deb's of the dream house for me the
dream house is important but I want an
eco home I want a nice big house when
people to have come today the dream
house is really important to me as part
of the dream and I just started writing
all these words these descriptive words
of who that person was like passionate
forceful energetic a benefactor like all
these words that were really just
they've just such powerful words for me
and then I wrote all these words on the
Debs now which was nice and lovely and
insecure like always kind of for me they
felt just kind of weaker words and as
soon as I saw that and I was like Deb's
now Deb's the dream house as soon as I
saw that that really was a shift on that
Collective pacing Bella Nardo I don't
want to be this wimp flying just just I
was just so nervous I was like no these
words are my words and that's what I'm
going so powerful Jim Rohn says that he
wanted to be a millionaire not because
he wanted a million pounds but because
of whom he knew he'd become yeah on that
journey to get yeah yeah would you say
you were much bigger person so much
bigger I think back to when I was at
school it's a silent they'll say
anything to anyone
must have terrified of everything but
you've got you've you've faced the fear
yeah and you got to the root of the
problem yeah it's interesting because
you know you can think Oh what if I had
we've had lots of properties that I
wouldn't be anxious but actually be more
anxious oh my gosh yeah you know there's
more stuff to worry right and again Jim
Rohn he says don't wish it was easier
wish you were better yeah that's good
and it's interesting because when you
came to me and you said you know look
I've done legacy yeah and and people
said that to me sometimes I said look
I've done it before if someone comes to
me and says I did this training this
training the chance training and none of
it worked but Samuel unknown yours is
getting different I'm like hmm there's a
common denominator
no you're bashing all these property
trainers and that didn't work yeah but
I'm like actually you know what
just hold it I don't want you to bring
my stats down right there's a common
denominator and the pattern is that
you're not taking action yeah and I'm
not gonna be able to wave a magic wand
I'm gonna give you the - let me give you
the training but if it's never worked in
the past it might not be because of
those trainers and what because of you
and I we've really direct people like
that but with with yourself and Pete
your husband you know you're like done
legacy and how did it go it was amazing
we're financially free oh man you need
to join the economy there yeah because
then it's like you put a pound and slot
machine - pinecones like you're just
gonna keep doing everyone over do you
think you're always invest money in your
own education in yourself oh my goodness
yeah just keep it absolutely cuz you
can't grow on your own because you don't
know you don't know yeah I don't know
what my blind spots are and I want to
get rid of when we went spots so I'll do
whatever and I think as well for me I'm
wanting things on
realizing there's just environment the
important environment being around
people that are doing what you want to
be doing if you if your five best
friends are broke yeah to be wealthy and
to be changing the planet you know so
just being in the environment
environment is better than well power if
you wake up and you think I'm gonna I'm
gonna do this I'm gonna I'm gonna call
agents today I'm gonna need lots of
houses but you're on your own it's gonna
be so tough and I think being around
people that are doing that it becomes
impossible for you to fail because other
people are doing yeah yeah it's just
great having people like you and P
joining the Academy almost as an asset
because another thing is people
sometimes and I get it and it's no
problem it's fine and on the same and
I've done courses but it's like what can
I get from going to this course we're
going to get from the academies act but
actually what can you breathe yeah
you're gonna be you're gonna be coming
to these events and come to these
training programs and part of this
community you like what are you what are
you gonna be what are you gonna be
bringing in and it's a totally different
question
don't ask what can I get all the time I
think success successful people instead
of saying what can I get from the
country well tonight so what kind of
bring yeah and then an unsuccessful mind
is always what can I get what can I get
my coming here I need to start off with
if you're just talking now there's
nothing wrong you know so be a sponge
get all the information but at some
point you're gonna have to make a
decision when I'm going to start giving
when am I gonna start you know which is
which is your journey now yeah so I
think if you have that kind of
entitlement mindset it actually cripples
you because you think that everybody
owes you something and that you need to
get something yeah you know and that
actually prevents you from making any
steps yes as soon as you want to
contribute you actually can contribute
to yourself because you're you're
helping yourself on the way as soon as
you think it you deserve it yeah then
how can you do any actions in order to
get successful in the first place what
did you do before you got into property
Isis doing administration I was a PA
okay yeah yeah a lot better it was
alright I just loved the freedom yeah
for me actually it was more important to
get Peter
his job that was my win mm well about a
year and a half ago it could have
happened sooner but we decided to give
ourselves a bit more wiggle room to
build you know so we weren't just
scraping by our financial freedom figure
but the reason we got into property in
the first place was Pisa was unhappy
Pete was still at university and as he
kind of got to the end of his course it
kept on saying things like oh this is a
death sentence I'm just this is all I'm
been working for the next 50 years I
just can't do it I can't do it
and I was kind of kings I thought oh my
gosh I've married a bum I'm gonna be
providing for this guy while he's in
some coffee shop writing poetry I was
like having a bit of a panic about it I
just remember him saying things over and
over and I was just trying to like just
yeah but you get a job cuz that's what
you do because we need you know we wanna
have a family like how were supposed to
get house I just didn't get it at all
and then we read Rich Dad Poor Dad yeah
and that just changed everything the
catalyst for many people is its massive
it's completely changed completely
changed our lives and that's what got us
on the journey in the first place what
would be your best piece of advice to
someone that really wanted financial
freedom and that's sort of starting out
won't be the best place you can is that
embracing embrace your weakness yes I
think one thing that's really helpful
with that is doing some personality
tests so we do we've done any ground
recently we've done life languages
you've done myers-briggs we've done a
lot of personality tests work out what
your strengths are and what your
weaknesses are and then I really go for
it on your weaknesses and figure out
what you need to do in order to be
successful yeah and fine just find out
what those weak points are and as soon
as you can kind of embrace those and
move move on that it kind of gives you
motivation and energy to get going yeah
that's really good someone watching this
video right now when they turn the video
off yeah what's the immediate action
points that you would suggest they do
look at my youtube channel yeah of
course all in the description yep just
get on Rightmove
yeah I just feel like people scroll on
my move like they do on social media so
you have to be careful with it because
you can get sucked into it but actually
it's an amazing tool and so much what
we've done in your course is you're
always on Rightmove
yeah but you just on it you do you're
just
how to use it effectively you need to be
looking in the right area yeah look if
you can't before very much then just cut
north or go to South Wales right you
know just start just get on there and
put some viewing because until you
really go and visit these houses this
doesn't feel it's just a pipe dream you
just need to get them right move I just
booked some things in even if the fumes
don't work it doesn't matter because
I've seen you could get out there you're
learning and you can start thing like Oh
like you know so many Victorian terraced
houses I saw most of our portfolio
Victorian terraces like we just needed
to go to hundreds of them to learn what
all the problems were and so each time
you do a viewing you just learn it's
time I love that so it's good advice I
mean I describe either the crash course
I describe a property viewing as an
appointment women estate agent
so rather that rather than seen it as
like oh is this house good I'll do a
spreadsheet on it and let's do all of
you do it yeah and if it's a rubbish
house say to the agent actually this is
a rubbish house for me yeah here's why
here's what I'm actually looking for
explain and see is an important one this
is what happens at the crash course
Freddie because people so a lot of
people like probably 95 percent the
people who watch my videos I've never
been so just give us a few so much fun
Samuel you were just such high energy
like the whole time I don't even know
how you do it and want you can take a
bouncing you just teach us just the
basics of how to get started in all the
different strategies so you cover like
to let you cover lease options rent to
rent
I think you just really do it step by
step of how to get there and you do it
on the stage you'll be on Rightmove you
burn spare room on gumtree
ringing them up speaking to agents I
just get to see all firsthand and that
just takes a lot of fear out yeah that's
awesome well it's been a real pleasure
getting to know you and I can't wait to
see technically them because I know that
you're you know you'd be good people
good heart and good energy and it's just
a personality so thank you so much for
coming on the show
[Music]